open AI went
um stop being non-profit or split up in
Detroit can you describe that whole
process yes we started as a non-profit
um we learned early on that we were
going to need far more Capital than we
were able to raise as a non-profit
um our non-profit is still fully in
charge there is a subsidiary capped
profit so that our investors and
employees can earn a certain fixed
return
and then beyond that everything else
flows to the nonprofit and the
non-profit is like in voting control
lets us make a bunch of non-standard
decisions
can cancel Equity can do a whole bunch
of other things can let us merge with
another org
um
protects us from making decisions that
are not in any like shareholders
interest
s uh so I think as a structure that has
been important to a lot of the decisions
we've made what went into that decision
process uh for taking a leap from
non-profit to capped for-profit
what are the pros and cons you're
deciding at the time I mean this was uh
it was 19. it was really like
to do what we needed to go do we had
tried and failed enough to raise the
money as a non-profit we didn't see a
path forward there so we needed some of
the benefits of capitalism but not too
much I remember at the time someone said
you know as a non-profit not enough will
happen as a for-profit too much will
happen so we need this sort of strange
intermediate foreign
you kind of had this offhand comment of
you worry about the uncapped companies
that play with AGI
can you elaborate on the worry here
because AGI out of all the Technologies
we have in our hands is the potential to
make is uh the cap is a hundred X
for open AI it started is that it's much
much lower for like new investors now
you know AGI can make a lot more than
100x for sure and so how do you um
like how do you compete like stepping
outside of open AI how do you look at a
world where Google is playing where
apple and these and meta are playing we
can't control what other people are
gonna do
um we can try to like build something
and talk about it and influence others
and provide value and you know good
systems for the world but
they're gonna do what they're gonna do
now
I I think right now there's like
extremely fast and not super deliberate
motion inside of some of these companies
but already I think people are as they
see
the rate of progress
already people are grappling with what's
at stake here and I think the better
angels are going to win out
can you elaborate on that to better
angles of individuals the individuals
and the companies but you know the
incentives of capitalism to create and
capture unlimited value
I'm a little afraid of
but again no I think no one wants to
destroy the world no one except saying
like today I want to destroy the world
so we've got the Malik problem on the
other hand we've got people who are very
aware of that and I think a lot of
healthy conversation about how can we
collaborate to minimize
some of these very scary downsides